on joue on nous remercie nous accueillir
dans votre centre de recherche peu plus
à l'époque
votre collègue docteurs je n'ai avait un
rêve de créer à montréal un centre de
recherche qu'elle est important sur la
planète est ce qu'il a réussi ce rêve là
c'est une grande réussite parce que les
paramètres qui l'avait qu'il avait
décrit à ce moment là était d'avoir une
institution indépendante avec liberté
académique ou des chercheurs pourraient
donc passé tout leur temps dans le
laboratoire et où la technique selon les
cas afin de découvrir certains
mécanismes physiologiques
c'est un mécanisme pathologique afin de
trouver les bons médicaments sont des
manades vu qu'il avait choisi c'était
d'hypertension artérielle
je vous rappeler qu'en 1960 au moment de
la fondation de descendre le département
de recherche et 65 ou dans la création
d'instituts on mourait d'hypertension a
dit que les parts tension était mortel
grâce aux travaux du triolet et de
beaucoup d'autres à travers le monde ont
beaucoup de ses élèves
maintenant on ne meurt plus
d'hypertension on est des complications
manifestation n'est pas une maladie
mortelle
donc il ya des découvertes qui ont
champions qui ont eu lieu ici à montréal
qui ont changé la donne scientifique
pour l'hypertension
c'est ça son hypothèse de masse était
très saine c'est que le sel de table
était la cause majeure de l'hypertension
et qui si on pouvait découvrir les
façons de contrôler la selle soit en
diminuant à l'abstention ou en l'air
très tendue line on pouvait dire contre
les multiples attentions dont jusqu'à
lui aussi mais au delà de tout ça il
s'est pas limitée pour les études
alimentation et inviter d'autres gros à
travailler sur d'autres sujets de sorte
que l'expansion est devenu
extrêmement important dans d'autres
domaines comme les glandes endocrines
comme des hormones par exemple qui était
le domaine que j'ai choisi ça c'est vous
ça oui vous êtes entré dans la rousse
aujourd'hui oui on n'est pas en
compétition mais je pourrais dire que
pour décrire mon frère jean ces deux
lignes des deux mois ceiling donc pour
une fois jusqu'au régnant pouvez vous
m'expliquer est-ce que ce que je vais
comprendre vous m'expliquer ce que vous
avez découvert
oui c'est quand j'étais tout jeune était
de 7 barclays à travers la chimie la
connaissance de la chimie des hormones
il propose une théorie qui dit qu' on
fabrique des armes à partir de molécules
inactive qui deviennent actives donc à
ce moment là se tirent dessus avec un
peu un peu de
de cette façon le rythme ou socialement
prenez ce serment mona lisa ou oies et
50 habitants lors tous deux ont un
mouchard d'une panoplie de développement
très intéressant mais qu'est ce que ça
change dans ma vie dans la vie des gens
c'est ce que ce que vous avez découvert
ça change beaucoup de traitement des
eaux et de connaissance des maladies
endocrine incluant le cholestérol le
touche au cholestérol parce que je n'ai
dans sa vision avait dit si on les
crises cardiaques et d'hypertension mais
c'est aussi le cholestérol et y habiter
d'être d'avignon qui était un des
anciens stagiaires comme moi et à
l'abattoir sur le cholestérol qui est
devenu mondialement reconnue docteur qui
était exprimant quelque chose les gens
se disent souvent peut-être la recherche
comme ça elle se fait dans les grandes
compagnies pharmaceutiques cas se fait
pas de manière indépendante
vous vous dites ou contraire c'est
important que cette recherche
fondamentale et appliquée après se fasse
de manière indépendante vêtements de
compagnies pharmaceutiques ici la boule
pour ne pas l'être non plus nous le mot
crise et la liberté a aimé mais à quel
moment les compagnies pharmaceutiques
prennent le relais et disent merci
beaucoup on prend vos travaux on s'en va
avec ce groupe on va développer la
molécule pour la haute pression pour le
cholestérol etc et de progresser pendant
la masse et dans le sens que rené paugam
n'aime pas prendre de risques autant que
nous c'est sa voix la gta ds que le goût
a fait la recherche médicale mais
l'argent
c'est un investissement du gouvernement
votre frère qui était à la tête du
canada est ce que vous l'avez souvent
chalet en disant j'ai besoin d'argent
pour les recherches il faut qu'au canada
on investit dans nos centres de
recherche ou de lui expliquer très tôt
très tôt trop que c'était essentiel pour
une société d'avoir d'art chez lui je
suis aussi que c'était un chèque en
blanc et c'est un peu comme les artistes
quand on demande un artiste de
percussions lwini pour quoi faire est-ce
qui vous a écouté selon ce qu'on dit
c'est lorsqu'on a pas de progrès théo g
à ne jamais autant d'investissements de
recherche que ce sont les yeux donc
décembre de clients y compris il y avait
bien expliqué faut dire qui comprend 10
et vous y avez bien expliquer
l'importance de la recherche
fondamentale est-ce que c'est toujours
le cas est ce que le canada prend assez
au sérieux la recherche fondamentale
dans des centres comme celui là il ya un
recul
ça va être partisane ya le recul des
années de les années 2010-2012 et sa
ferme pouvoir reprendre mais tel point
qu'on aimerait donc au succès rentable
la preuve est faite que c'est rentable
socio économiquement mais on doit
laisser les gens décider ce qu'ils font
pas des subventions
quelle est la réputation de l'insu de
recherche de montréal sur la scène
internationale où on se situe par
rapport à d'autres centres
même si on est relativement petit la
réputation mondiale comme on peut
l'apprécier de par les stagiaires sont
ici claude millet leaders locaux alors
en france un des raids de genève d'être
joie de mana et de grands gourous de la
recherche médicale en france celui qu'a
connu la plage quand l'alzheimer avec
monsieur sarkozy enchaîne ses
soutiennent qu est devenu ménès
d'affronter donc élèves aussi et lacées
6 6 2 à annaba en allemagne c'est d'être
gay aussi le grath vis à vis de
l'hypertension en allemagne et de la
recherche médicale
donc c'est vraiment joyau méconnu c'est
un joyau méconnu d'accord avec vous
parce que la science est moins connu et
dacia thenelles n'attire pas autant
natation c'était pire comme ça parce que
si on attire trop l'attention
on peut que provoquer dans de faux
espoirs
aidez-la nous appelle comme ça les deux
temps deux hôtesses que vous allez
régler mon problème médical nous ont
aidés on va c'est on va vous aider en
espérant que la bonne solution
vous êtes heureux toujours là votre
salaire ça me passionne moi je peux
travailler est abonné mais ça a été un
plaisir de vous rencontrer mais si bonne
suite des choses ici pour réussir
maintenant
à fait